hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and horikoshi just
trolled everyone new characters suddenly
joined the battle and the truth about
the civilians who were hiding out at UA
including deku's mom may have just taken
an extremely dark turn on top of that I
think that deku's Dad may be finally
coming back from the store after getting
the milk there is a lot to talk about
tons of twists and turns so let's get
into it you guys know how this works if
you enjoy our videos and you want to see
more mha videos in the future leave a
click like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it helps us with
that YouTube algorithm and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch our
videos regularly but still haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a big
favor and subscribe right now if you
want to do me an even bigger favor you
can also hit that Bell and select the
option that says all finally this video
will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the last few chapters were
marked by the heroes receiving some very
unexpected reinforcements from a number
of former villains including gentle La
Brava and Lady Nagant they all decided
to join the fight on the UA Battlefield
on the side of the heroes the previous
chapter also revealed that shigaraki
knew all along what all for one's real
plan was and he hated the idea of
becoming nothing more than all for one's
tool but because he couldn't resist all
for one openly he secretly planned a way
to fight back he did this by hiding away
his own tragic Origins deep within his
heart and then waiting for the right
moment to release his true personality
and overcome all for one's control
tomura shigaraki and tenko shimura still
share one goal and it is a goal that has
nothing to do with all for one's
Ambitions or with stealing one for all
shigaraki wants to destroy everything
that made what happened in his childhood
home possible and it is that desire to
destroy everything that his childhood
home represents that really keeps him
going at the end of the last chapter
Deku and shigaraki were just about to
begin their final battle on the ground
but even though Deku forced shigaraki to
get off of the UA floating structure and
get down to the ground the UA is still
in danger of plummeting down and killing
everyone who is still there and that is
exactly where the latest chapter picks
up although he managed to prevent the
collapse of the UA temporarily gentle is
now struggling to keep it up as the
elasticity of his Quirk reaches its
limits despite being powered up by La
brava's immense love gentle has reached
the limit of his abilities and it looks
like he's seconds away from from being
crushed to death along with everyone
else who is still inside the UA and
honestly I'm glad horikoshi brought some
more focus on this because when we first
saw gentle saving the UA I did feel like
this feat was Way Beyond anything I
would have expected from him and his
Quirk at least based on everything we
knew up to that point in time now of
course yes La Brava is using her Quirk
to heavily boost his power and now that
they've found each other again I'm sure
her love is even stronger than ever
before but still I'm glad that gentle
isn't just like easily holding up the
entire UA only with his Quirk he's
definitely struggling and he's at the
end of his rope and La Brava is rushing
to get the UA systems back online before
gentle is killed alongside everyone else
so yeah as I said gentle is really
pushing himself to the Limit and even
though he is staring death in the face
he feels the joy of Life filling up his
heart now there are no cameras here and
no one even know knows that he's the one
holding the UA up in the past gentle
always wanted cameras and an audience he
wanted Fame and notoriety but now that
he's risking his life with no one even
being aware that he's there allows him
to understand what a true hero feels
this is real selfless and
self-sacrificing heroism and this
knowledge feels gentle with joy now of
course we know that gentle is wrong Deku
and the others did realize that gentle
was the one who saved the UA and a
couple of students from the UA
Management Department starts peeking out
of the building and they begin filming
gentle with their smartphones gentle
yells at them to get back inside because
it's too dangerous but the students
reply that they're just doing their job
part of their job is to manage public
relations between the heroes and the
public and yet the entire hero Society
failed to do that after the last
disastrous War again the villains
instead of bringing the heroes and the
public together the entire hero Society
fractured and now the situation is worse
than ever so these Management Department
students are determined to show how
gentle a former villain is now here
risking his life to protect the heroes
they want this message to go out across
the country Heroes regular people and
even former villains can come together
to protect the world from the real evil
from all for one and shigaraki and
together they can create a better future
gentle is impressed when he hears this
and he feels ashamed that he ever
considered breaking into a school with
such amazing students meanwhile the
management department students notice
that their phones are no longer obeying
their commands they are being hijacked
we then realized that La Brava has
already managed to restore the UA's
flotation systems and she is now hacking
in into the students phones in order to
broadcast their footage of gentle live
across the entire country with the most
passionate and loving look on her face
she declares that she can't let gentle's
legendary Deeds go unseen by the rest of
the world even if he himself is fine
with that but even as the UA seems to be
out of immediate danger at least as far
as crashing violently to the ground goes
the people inside the UA building are
not out of danger yet that's because
those twice clones who appeared as a
result of Sad Man's parade are still
there and multiplying like crazy man
their goal just happens to be to
slaughter every single hero in fact it
looks like they're about to take at
least two Heroes down with them right
now as both izawa and present Mike are
forced off the UA platform by the twice
clones and in that moment it looks like
President Mike and izawa are about to
plunge to their deaths however that is
when kurogiri
recognizes them and realizes that he has
to protect them he then uses warp gate
to rescue them before they crash to the
ground this is a major development but
at the same time though we don't really
know where president Mike and izava
ended up because the portal just
disappears after it takes them in so
while we can certainly assume that they
are both alive and we can also assume
that obero is slowly waking up inside of
kurogiri we also have to come to terms
with the fact that erasing shigaraki's
quirks is now out of the question aizawa
is now gone and we don't know where he
is so from this point forward there will
be no way of erasing shigaraki's quirks
the villain will likely be at full power
for the rest of the battle the chapter
then shifts Focus back to gunga where
all for one and even more twice clones
are still fighting against the heroes
there including of course endeavor Hawks
and several class 1a students among
others but before we get to that fight
can we take a second to talk about the
fact that the management department at
the UA actually exists basically this
Department's job is to manage the
heroics business to deal with things
like public relations to manage hero
agencies to monitor public opinion about
heroes and stuff like that they are
literally just like business and
marketing students am I remembering this
wrong or did the manga not make a huge
deal in the beginning about only
powerful hero students being able to get
into UA and that is why Deku initially
had no chance of getting in because he
was quirkless like from everything that
we know about the management department
you don't need a quirk to be a part of
it so Deku totally could have joined
this department even if he was quirkless
and then potentially he could try to get
into one of the hero courses later on
like shinso ended up doing it's just a
little side note but I do find it weird
how these guys who don't necessarily
need to be strong or heroic themselves
are still part of Japan's most
prestigious hero School the UA moving on
the situation at gunga is also very dire
as the twice clones are swarming the
battlefield and the heroes there
including Pixie bob and others are just
absolutely getting overwhelmed Hawks is
still attempting to stop all for one
from leaving gunga and reaching
shigaraki and in that moment all for one
is kind enough to provide us with a
useful info dump that tells us exactly
what he's up to essentially shigaraki's
desire for Destruction the one that was
born out of his tragic childhood turned
out to be much stronger than all for one
had anticipated and so he was unable to
silence this part of shigaraki's
Personality as a result he was unable to
completely control and dominate his new
vessel but all for one also explains
that once he forces shigaraki to absorb
all for ones work Factor his personality
will be sealed away permanently and all
for one will be able to dominate the new
vessel after all he is the Demon Lord
and he believes that the Demon Lord is
the real hero of this story but Hawks
refuses to accept that this is all for
one story and despite being injured he
is still fighting desperately to keep
all for one from reaching shigaraki
Hawks is fighting for the sake of the
future for the sake of the next
generation of Heroes and he refuses to
let all for one win for his part all for
one is already certain of Victory and he
believes that the Winds of Fortune are
blowing his way in the next moment all
for one unleashes a quirk that seems to
shred hawks's body into pieces tokoyami
screams out with tears in his eyes as
Hawks turns into a character from oron
High School Host Club and then
disappears into nothing and so so our
boy Hawks is dead totally dead
definitely 100 percent dead okay I admit
this got me for like a few seconds
because I think that Hawks dying in this
Arc is possible especially if it's set
up like a way for him to atone for his
sins including the Betrayal and killing
of twice but it turns out that this was
not really Hawks who was Torn to Pieces
by all for one this was an illusion
created by Cami from shiketsuhai because
in that very moment the shiketsu
students we met back in the provisional
hero license exam Arc arrive on the
battlefield as you might recall from
back then Cami has a quirk called glamor
which allows her to create illusions of
other people along with Kami inasa and
seiji from shiketsu are also here and
seiji had used his disgusting Quirk to
keep the real Hawks back while kami's
illusion tricked all for one apparently
these shikitsu students were supposed to
escort the civilians who were evacuated
from UA through the secret tunnels which
led all the way to their school but for
some reason these civilians never showed
up because of this the shikitsu students
figured that something was wrong and
decided to come out and check things out
the shikitsu guys are itching to fight
all for one and the villains and to give
some much needed backup to the heroes as
inasa begins using his wind Quirk to
create a bunch of tornadoes that start
blowing away those twice clones he asks
all for one how dare he say that the
Winds of Fortune are blowing his way
when he inasa is the one who makes the
wind blow and that is how this chapter
ends honestly straight up this was a
great one-liner by inasa and in general
this was a shocking and exciting
entrance by the shikitsu student I mean
we all knew these guys would come back
to the story at some point because
they're all quite powerful especially
inasa so it wouldn't make sense for them
to stay out of the final battle
completely and I think the way they were
brought back made perfect sense but
that's actually the most interesting
part of this entire chapter for me I
mean a lot of great stuff happened the
whole kurogiri thing and everything else
going on but the fact that civilians
from the UA who were supposed to be
evacuated from the tunnels never showed
up is really interesting that is what we
need to talk about right now because I
think we are about to finally meet
deku's father and I will explain why
okay so many chapters ago it was
established that two of all for one
spies infiltrated the civilian
evacuation shelters that were located on
the UA grounds these spies were sent by
all for one apart from the traitor and
his parents who were also there
horikoshi also made it a point to have
skeptic mentioned several times how
important it is for him to gain access
to the evacuation shelters security
systems now we just learned that these
civilians at UA were supposed to be
evacuated through the underground
tunnels and the shiketsu students were
supposed to escort them but the evacuees
never showed up to me this can only mean
one thing we know that all for one has
many plans and backup plans and one of
these plans involves getting his hands
on the civilians at the UA evacuation
shelter now you might be thinking why
does he care about these civilians but
all for one likely knows that the
parents of many of the hero students
will be in these shelters including of
course deku's own mother inko and what
better way to force Deku to obey you and
maybe even willingly give one for all to
you than by taking his own mother
hostage and threatening her life unless
Deku complies with your demands we can't
forget that all for one has been trying
to steal one for all for literally
generations and he always failed because
one for all can only be transferred with
the consent of the current user so what
if he's planning to Blackmail Deku into
consenting by threatening the person
closest to him his mother and if this is
what all for one is planning to do and
if this is where the story is going then
what better time to finally introduce
deku's father than right now the story
is ending time is running out and
horikoshi promised that he would
introduce deku's dad before the manga
ends he's kept all his other promises
like revealing the identity of the
traitor so there's no way that he just
forgot about deku's Dad there are a lot
of people who believe that deku's Dad
might be a villain or even all for one
himself and if that is the case then now
is the time for him to reveal himself
and lure inko into a trap in order to
Blackmail Deku but if deku's Dad is not
a villain and he's actually a normal guy
then the idea of all for one and the
villains threatening inko and the other
evacuees is the perfect opportunity for
deku's father to make his grand entrance
as he returns from abroad to defend his
wife I really get the feeling that all
for one is in fact planning something
with the civilians inside the UA shelter
and that this will be the moment that
horikoshi finally introduces us to
Hisashi midoriya if I'm wrong feel free
to mock me in the comments of my future
videos I will gladly take the heat but
don't forget that in order to mock me
you have to subscribe and hit that
notification button first so you don't
forget about it later what do you guys
think am I right to think that the UA
shelters are a part of all for one's
plan and is deku's Dad about to be
introduced let me know down below if
you're looking for a video to watch next
check out our growing mha playlist we
got a ton of videos ready for you guys
to view right now and the link is on
screen and in the description as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys